面にちょっと最近ちょっと忙しくてこう入れてドーンと構えて動画を撮るて時間が
あんまりなくて
例えばとになっておりますもうひと頑張りです
もうひと頑張りすれば多分家でゆっくりできる時間がとれると思うのでもしばしこう
いうなんかいろんなところで動画を撮りますね今なんですけども更地が隣の部屋で寝
てるんですよ
別んですけどもまぁこのオレ様が普通にで行かせるわけないぞということで協調の1階
に良い睡眠よねちょっと僕がで彼に提供してあげようと思ってます先ちょっと見つけた
んですけどみなさんこのと聞いたことありますでしょうか
流します
はい分かりますでしょうか可能なつとかね不幸なんか夜寝れないじゃないですか
は猿いてわかると思いますよかめっちゃうるさくないか今日はねちょっと明日早いんで
もう食べ隣で寝てる育ち
に快適な睡眠を送ってもらいたいということで私
はじめ金プラついのてるところにこの可能とねその bgm として
ラクゼーション校
なんとしてちょっと送りつけて彼にじっくり寝てもらおうと思っているわけでござい
ます
8倍ズームだに言われたからだか僕ってバレたくないですね今回僕ってバレたくないん
である方法を使ってこの音だけを育ちもところに届きます
すっ
僕も早く寝なきゃいけないですよ
あー数
スピンなよく考えてみ後輩に可能とを聴かせるために徹夜で起きている
この大先輩ですよ
よしっ
佐々木カメラだけゲットしていきますコストにソラっちーの部屋の鍵もバックってき
ました
行ってきます
ブーム
持った
あっはぁ
ございます
me
なんで労基かー
寝てていいよねっていう思って作っ
お前ていくスレ
ん
おっ
4日
ん
がします
はぁ
e 4
います
しています